good morning John and Hank it's Friday
so this October I had my first music
release since my record came out three
years ago I was on tour at the time and
spent the hour before the EP came out
cry what you think was probably
surprised to my friends would you know
it does seem like a weird response but
those and many of my other friends also
had releases coming out in the next
couple of months and they all told me
that they had a similar experience that
hours before their EPS came out a few of
my friends told me that releasing
something is a bit like giving birth
it's painful which i think is like close
to the I think that's close to the
feeling but I don't think it's quite
right
I think a better analogy is it's a bit
like sending your kid off to college for
a year my art was mine to have and hold
and enjoy and now it's leaving and it
doesn't belong to me anymore no this is
especially hard if you like many artists
put your identity in your art what if
people don't like it what if people
think it's not good enough what if
people like me it's hard to create
anything and it's even hmm I don't know
if it's even harder to put it out there
both very hard for similar reasons I
think before you go through the
execution of making something it exists
in your head and in your head it's a
perfect idea perfect execution perfect
everything it's beautiful but when you
go through the pain of creating
something you have to look into the face
of your inadequacy and sometimes this is
like a lack of literal hardware you know
you couldn't afford something you needed
or sometimes it's this is the first
thing I've ever made and I don't know
how to do it well yet here's a quote
from Ira Glass about being a beginner
and an artist nobody tells us - the
people who are beginning I wish someone
told me all of us who do creative work
we get into it because we have good
taste but there is this gap for the
first couple of years you make stuff
it's just not that good
it's trying to be good it has potential
but it's not but your taste the thing
that got you in the game is still killer
and your taste is why your work
disappoints you hourglass I love you so
yeah I do think that this fear of an
adequate
see and this fear of maybe rejection
when it comes to actual release is the
reason that lots of people never create
at all it's very vulnerable to say I
made this and I like it maybe even more
vulnerable to say I made this and I
wanted to like it but I don't but that's
part of learning and that's a part of
being a beginner I don't know what's my
point here uh I guess my point is its
natural to grieve the loss of ownership
and the loss of the safety of what
something was before you put it out and
when creating its natural to fear your
own inadequacy but neither of those are
good reasons to not try John I'll see
you Friday Tuesday Tuesday Oh also hi my
name is Tessa violet I make video blogs
and original music Hey woof
[Music]
I was on tour at the time hello huh